you're under the state of minnesota rest
thank you
the defense opened its case by putting
george floyd on trial
turning the court's attention from
former police officer derrick chauvin to
the man he's accused of murdering
you put your hands on the dash the
defense theory is that floyd died of
heart trouble and a drug overdose
to support that chauvin's lawyers called
a police officer and a paramedic who
testified
that floyd took opioid pills when he was
arrested in a separate 2019
encounter prosecutor aaron eldridge
fired back
mr floyd didn't drop dead while you were
interacting with him correct
no thank you the floyd family calls the
attacks on him
character assassination of a dead man
police officers
are killing us and we are being murdered
at a rate that i
never thought i could imagine it's a
time for change
and that time is now minneapolis you all
can't sweep this under the rug anymore
we're here and we will fight for justice
for this family hoping to link the two
arrests
the defense then showed police body
camera footage from the fateful day of
may 25th
shawanda hill was in the car with floyd
when police first arrived
he instantly grabbed the wheel and he
was like please please don't kill me
please please don't shoot me don't shoot
me
much of day 12 was spent on the
defense's star witness of the day
a police expert who said that in
kneeling on george floyd's neck for nine
and a half minutes
derek shovin did absolutely nothing
wrong
in your opinion was this a use of deadly
force it was not
i felt that officer shovin's
interactions with mr floyd
were following his training following
current practices in policing and were
objectively reasonable
prosecutor steve slicer pushed back
noting chauvin held floyd down long
after he had not only stopped resisting
but was apparently dead did you hear
at some point in your review officer
king say that he couldn't find a pulse
yes all of this would have been known to
a reasonable officer in the defendant's
position
correct yes and the defendant's position
is and was and remains as we see here at
this moment and this time in this clip
on top of mr floyd on the street isn't
that right
yes i have nothing further
with the defense expected to wrap up its
testimony this week
one big unanswered question is whether
chauvin himself
will take the stand john hendren al
jazeera minneapolis